I definitely would not want
to fall from this height.
We need to get to the
hive out of the branches
and lower it down.
We're going to bring it down.
We're going to lower it.
This thing is
heavy, yeah, I have it.
Bees release pheromones when
they're threatened so Joseph
uses smoke to disrupt their
sense of smell and stop them
from swarming.
The bees are acting up, but
the smoke is doing its job.
HAZEN: Ok, we have
everything locked off up here.
The hive is
almost to the ground.
Suspended.
We've got the hive
down but we're not
going in for the honey just yet.
The Okiek know that the bees
are reluctant to fly at night,
and are far more docile.
So, for now we must wait
for the light to fade.
Now is the time.
It's plenty dark enough now.
It's not getting
any darker than this.
So, by firelight, we're going
to dig right into that hive.
They're really
buzzing around in there.
The kind of bees these
are East African honeybees.
A big hive like this
can have 40,000 bees.
Being stung in
numbers can be fatal.
If they swarm the
risk is very real.
There's a trap door on
the bottom of this hive.
They're blowing more
and more smoke in there.
Heart of the hive
with the honey.
There it is,
that's it right there.
That's what
we're talking about.
Those bees are angry now.
They're starting to fly out.
Ba-ba-ba-ba! Aye!
HAZEN: Ahhh right in the
armpit, that's a bad one.
The smoke is preventing a
swarm but some bees are
still going in for the attack.
When they crawl on you.
They just sting
whatever feels like skin.
Ah! I've got one under my shirt,
and I've already
been stung about,
I don't know, six or seven
times, I don't know.
These guys are
getting stung, too.
They're working fast,
trying to get the honeycomb.
Oh.
Oh, my gosh.
Heavy with honey.
And then those white parts,
those are little baby honeybees,
which isn't honey,
but it is protein.
Might seem like a lot of work
to get honey but think about it,
there is nothing out
here sweeter than honey.